[Music]
I'm just curious is anybody here on a
date just curious any but you are okay
because if this is where you took her on
Valentine's Day you're not getting any
I'm just promise you take her to Tavis
Smiley all right that's the show smiley
will get you laid that's their that's
their motto now in the show all right I
got some Valentine's Day news for you
this is good news Papa John's is
offering a heart-shaped pizza for
Valentine's Day
nice yeah it's a it's for the wife who
has everything except a husband who
knows what a woman wants for Valentine's
Day
God your heart-shaped people I got these
covered honey
I ate half of it on the way home it was
a hard I'm pretty much a hero
yeah for Valentine's Day Time Warner
Cable is offering a special channel
called Ryan Gosling on demand ok ladies
are happy but I'm sorry Time Warner I'm
a guy okay so call me when you have
Robert Pattinson on demand that guy
wants to sleep with Robert Pattinson
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yesterday uh sworn on politics yesterday
Newt Gingrich Rick Santorum and Mitt
Romney all said that if elected
president they would eliminate porn in a
related story President Obama has
already been reelected unanimous yes we
can
this is the unanimous reaction of the
crowd eliminate Papa never seen a crowd
anchor your about any idea before I know
my people they like porn you're gonna
like this one
one person believes me one person went
check this out Paramount Pictures just
announced that they're going to come out
with transformers for ya
now you might like it in the new movie
transformers 3 transforms itself into a
good movie
[Applause]
why can I do that but I can't make a
heart the son of Playboy founder Hugh
Hefner has been arrested on a charge of
domestic violence you have nurse son
yeah when he heard this Hugh Hefner said
son there's a right way and a wrong way
to disrespect women
[Applause]
joke just does better with age reality
star Michelle Duggar who has 19 children
now says she'd like to try and have more
kids
yeah coincidentally while she was giving
you interview three more just fell out
of her they were fully clothed she's
okay now
but while vacationing in South Africa
Shakira was attacked by a sea lion she's
fine but a sea lion attacked Shakira
yeah this is not surprising two animal
experts since the sea lions natural
enemy is an amazing ass
it makes them crazy let's pretend that
one didn't happen
[Applause]
this is me just erasing sea lion attach
her ass I know this not helping much
today in my boss
I just so want to be you right now
let's be nice over there oh it's
fantastic